let's say there's this machine and the
machine makes toys the machine makes red
toys and the machine makes blue toys all
day long the machine makes blue and red
toys but then sometimes the machine
makes a purple toy and someone says this
is a blue toy because this machine only
makes blue or red toys so the purple toy
is a blue toy but then sometimes the
machine makes another purple toy and
someone says this is a red toy because
this machine only makes blue or red toys
so the purple toys try to fit in but one
day someone says maybe this machine also
makes purple toys and everyone stops for
a second because the world's been built
with the understanding that the machine
only makes blue toys or red toys blue
toys are mad because there may be purple
toys among them red toys too but it
would be much easier if red and blue
toys realize that the machine may be
more complicated than just making red
toys and blue toys the toys talk more
and more about the purple toys and
slowly considerations are made for
purple toys red toys and blue toys and
purple toys start to understand one
another they begin to learn more about
the machine and understand that the
machine is even more complicated and
fascinating than they had previously
thought
so they celebrate this blue toys and red
toys and purple toys together and then
sometimes the machine makes a green toy